trois,
je suis le bienvenu à
la répétition avec ma guitare sur le dos et le
sac de mon commerçant
je n'ai pas apporté de parapluie parce que j'ai
oublié qu'il pleuvait ouais ouais je
bascule cette vie de musicien nyc
c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé ma journée
et ça  n'a fait qu'empirer
oh
[Applaudissements]
j'aime les japonais, évidemment
euh, tirer sur le dernier samouraï était
extraordinaire, ils
fabriquent également des montres incroyables
juste l'étincelle
nissa scintille d'accord
dois-je aller faire un
accent australien pour le
marché australien nous avons bien fait le japon nous '  re bon
mouvement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'espère que
je ne sais pas comment
on va où on va
euh où on va je ne vais pas
vous le dire
mais ça va être amusant
bienvenue chez moi oh mon dieu elle est là
salut oh mon dieu
salut c'est tellement étrange c'est à
l'origine j'allais porter quelque chose
comme brillant et puis j'ai entendu que tu
portais du neutre je pensais juste que je
voulais parler comme moi
alors walmart
le porte pour toi c'était amusant
[Musique]
toi